good morning John today I'm gonna talk
about my punishment I'm going to show
you some of the stuff that I got on tour
but first I'm gonna play for you a song
that I wrote while I was on tour I'm
gonna shut up now and just play it
but I want to be a big star and I've
never really been a fan of folks who
just want to go farm but I do like to
play on this guitar and rat these stupid
songs in rental cars now I'm headed to
Los Angeles and I can't stop though I
really gotta piss cuz I'm late for the
show got ID all got a go over the pedal
to the metal and I'm burning up the road
and I get there with five minutes to
spare the people there they don't seem
to care hmm I strap on my guitar and get
ready to cut loose I hope these people
think that this machine pose
[Music]
moobs it's like a headshot with a flat
can and a start for mario or the big dot
in pac-man or the Konami code and it
make me feel invincible when I'm up
there on that stage the final boss has
been destroyed long distance or close
range it's like a sniping shotgun and
it's body armor too and I hope everyone
agrees that this machine constant
I just finished my show in Phoenix AZ
god damn it if I didn't lose my keys and
earth butters there all wanna hang out
and go to Yogurtland and in and out but
we have to wait there on this sidewalk
eating pizza with first officer Spock
and now that they have been introduced I
hope they agree that this machine pawns
[Music]
moobs it's like a headshot with a flat
can and a start for Mario or the big dot
impact man or the Konami code and it
makes me feel invincible when I'm up
there on that stage the level boss has
been destroyed long system sir close
range it's like a super sniping shotgun
and it's body armor too and I hope
everyone agree that this machine won't
move
[Music]
you
whoa now I'm gonna show you some of the
things that I got on the final part of
the tour this is a 10 sided die that was
made with a 3d printer like the nerdiest
of the nerdy because I complained in the
drug's episode about how he can't get
kinder eggs in America someone brought
them from Canada I already ate two of
them here the toys that it came with
somebody brought me cupcakes and I
finished the cupcakes and then found a
note inside that says Hank if you open
this on your video i will donate $15 to
children in need
so i'm opening it it's not the first
time I opened it but I am opening it
this is a wallet made of duct tape a
shirt for an para they make bass amp
Steve tbh a headband yeah probably the
coolest thing I have ever gotten while
on tour was this gigantic bag of stuff
from Dark Horse Comics ah not only did I
get like super stretchy Hellboy man this
is my favorite when you do this to his
head ah three giant signed posters this
one of Abe from hell boy and this one a
Buffy and a freaking stack of comics
including like expensive graphic novels
like traitors big with spines and stuff
this is exceptionally exciting it's the
new dr. Horrible's unfortunately John I
did not realize how long that song would
that'll be so I have to go I will show
you the rest of the stuff that I got on
tour and talk about the rest the stuff
that I wanted to talk about in a video
tomorrow John you will see me then